[Music]
it was up guys I'm Kip EFC here and as
you may or may not have heard a new
iPhone went on sale today if the new
second-generation iPhone se it costs
$399
so in 2020 a brand new iPhone for 399
now originally I wasn't going to talk
about this until I had it in hand but
hey quarantine content right why not
talk Tech for a little bit and there are
just so many interesting conversations
to be had because of this phone at this
price fun fact I already did talk about
it in depth on the wave form podcast so
if you want the long-form discussion
version of this it's the link below you
can listen to it anywhere but uh yeah
there's a lot to talk about the first of
all Apple's having themselves a little
hit year with minor refreshes so far in
2020 right we had the MacBook Air which
is basically a new keyboard and internal
speck bump same design and now it's
everyone's favorite laptop we got the
new iPad pro which is basically the same
iPad pro with a lidar camera and an
ultra-wide and a new GPU core BAM that's
just extending their lead as the best
tablet and so now we have the new iPhone
se so just so we're all on the same page
what is this iPhone se well if you
picture the body of an iPhone 8
literally like iPhone 8 cases will work
with this new se so imagine an iPhone 8
touch ID fingerprint reader and bezels
the whole thing the 4.7 inch retina HD
LCD display on the front ip67 wireless
charging aluminum rails little thing
you've seen an iPhone 8 but then on the
inside it has new internals
so it's speck bump against oh you got
the new a 13 Bionic which is the same
chip in a thousand dollar iPhone 11 Pro
and three gigs of ram and some other
little things if you're paying attention
they moved the Apple logo down to the
middle of the back of the phone now to
match all the newer iPhones so that's
how you be able to tell what's an S II
and what's an iPhone 8 and are dropping
it in three colors it is red black or
white and all three colorways will have
the black front bezels even the white
one so the white iPhone eight had white
bezels the white iPhone se has black
bezels so that's nice but really it's a
pretty simple formula some people have
called this a parts bin phone just
because Apple's recycling some
things they have you know take the a13
over here take the iphone a body they've
done this with the iPad in the past but
hey they slapped the iconic much-loved
SC name on it now it's everywhere well
actually it's the price that's making it
a crowd favorite that's why it's
everywhere but the SC name was smart too
so I have a couple thoughts on what make
this so crazy and so interesting and I'm
curious what your guys thoughts are but
number one will this be the best camera
in a budget phone and I think it's very
possible at least top two like right now
if you've watched any other smartphone
videos of mine you know the obvious
recommendation for a budget phone with a
great camera has been pixel 3a by a mile
because there really isn't any
competition in this price range for a
great camera this new iPhone se coming
along will have basically the same
hardware as the iPhone 8's camera a
single 12 megapixel shooter back there
plus the benefit of new image processing
from the iPhone 11 thanks to the a 13
Bionic so I suspect it's reasonable to
assume this camera will be at least as
good as the iPhone 8 if not a little bit
better
thanks to software and I think that puts
it right up there against pixel three a
it might not be pixel for a when that
comes out as far as camera quality but
video quality I'm gonna say this one's a
safe bet for best video quality and a
budget phone then number two Apple
joining the spec for low budget race
makes it really tough for a lot of the
Android manufacturers that have been
absolutely feasting down their C for the
longest time there has never been an
option to buy an iPhone a new iPhone at
that low of a price we've seen you know
every year new iPhone comes out it's
eight nine hundred a thousand dollars
even up from that and so they'll maybe
bump down the price of older iPhones
down to six hundred maybe five hundred
dollars but as soon as you wanted to go
lower than that there was no new iPhone
and so that's where one plus and Xiaomi
and Samsung would all be waiting for you
but now now there's a new iPhone with an
a 13 Bionic for $399 and that's an easy
choice for a lot of people that's that's
gonna sweep up the rest of the sales
that they were missing underneath the
price of the low
five phone they had before so that is
scary if you're one of those Android
manufacturers that's been basically
thriving at that lower price because of
the lower price like it just became a
really easy choice for a lot of people
I'm super curious actually to see the
day one week one sales for this iPhone
se then number three is this more likely
to be the best budget phone of the year
or the best compact phone of the year we
actually talked about this exact
question on the wave form podcast and
the answer we sort of landed on was
probably best compact phone 4.7 inch
display in the iPhone 8 body size is
compact by today's standards it's not
the it's not the good ol precious truly
se days that we I definitely miss but
we're really not expecting too many
other flagship quality phones at a
smaller size so maybe it's a lock
already for compact phone of the year
but I think we are likely to see more
options to come out and compete at this
price so we already know pixel for a is
probably coming up soon Samsung's always
dropping stuff at this price point we
always see all the other competitors
very active from 300 to 600 bucks so
we're expecting more competition there
but yeah as far as small phones it's
really easy to talk about how this is
not a new design obviously touch ID is
old and big bezels on the front are old
but I'll get back to that in a second
that's not exactly what people are
paying attention to add a $399 price but
anyway my bottom line right now you know
we've been exchanging thoughts about
this on Twitter but I think this is
Apple's best deal ever which maybe isn't
the highest bar ever from a company
that's also selling wheels to their
computer for $700 so you know it's a
great deal from Apple but it is also one
of the best deals in all of tech but you
really have to think about what most
people want what ninety-five percent of
people want I think we kind of sometimes
catch ourselves in this tech bubble
where we're always looking at the
bleeding edge high-tech stuff but really
it's a small percentage of us maybe
maybe 5% of us that care about you know
the design and being bezel lists and
having a hole-punch versus a notch
camera refresh rates all the sort of
stuff
it's a small percentage so on the face
of it this looks like a phone with
pretty much no downsides at this price
for like 90% of people go ask your your
mom or dad or your grandparents or your
honour uncle if they care about the
screen to body ratio or the spec sheet
of your phone the answer is probably no
and if you told them they could get a
brand new iPhone for 400 bucks and it
has the new a 13 Bionic and it's a
pretty great camera you can get it in
red black or white which is kind of what
I'm into it seems like a no-brainer I
think we still should reserve judgment
for the full review and we actually get
to use this thing
but I'm thinking okay what do people
care about a lot in a new phone screen
and you know this happens to be a 4.7
inch screen but it's the same pixel
density same color accuracy as the
iPhone 11 so that's fine they care about
camera and this is an iPhone camera this
is ideally iPhone eight quality or
better it seems pretty good they care
about battery life and honestly an a 13
Bionic in a screen this small probably
gonna do fine with battery and then
price and this is a $399 phone and it's
an iPhone so it's familiar people know
touch ID people know iOS and something
that's underrated with Apple stuff we
don't talk about this that much but
software updates the software updates
support for this $399 phone because it's
an iPhone and it'll get iOS updates for
probably four to five years is probably
the best for any $399 phone so there you
have it a lot of interesting stuff
coming from this iPhone se announcement
you know usually when we're talking
about new tech we're talking about the
highest end the bleeding edge of stuff
and that's what I like to focus on but I
guess the benefit of the world we live
in is now that all this stuff is getting
so good you can bring down almost the
bleeding edge tech way down in price and
get stuff like a $399 iPhone that
undercuts every single phone one plus
has come out with for the past two years
it's crazy time to be alive either way
that's been it thanks for watching this
quick first impression and catch you
guys very soon in the next one pace